hey what's up guys welcome to another
episode of get close I'm Geo and I'm
Bart and I'm really excited about
today's topic because I feel like we've
been together for a long time so we know
a lot about each other do we do we
though yeah okay because we talking
stuff you know we've been together since
2008 it's 2023 so that's 15 years total
we got married in what 2015. yep so
that's eight years of marriage okay
um but I feel like when you zoom in into
people's like
microcosms there's a lot of things that
people know zero about so for example
like with me in the military
uh there's like you might just know some
of them yeah I don't know anything about
other stories that I tell you yeah but
if you zoom in there's a lot of insight
on stuff like that yeah so I want to
know about you what are some like little
micro ecosystems or little things that
you've been part of and and what that's
like so like take me into like let's say
um when he played volleyball in high
school take me into that world oh [__]
you're telling me to go back what is
that like 22 years yeah I don't know if
I even remember that [__] so you would
have to ask but you have to be a good
host do you know what that's like nope
okay well do what I do every time we do
this and ask a ton of questions because
there's no way I'm gonna remember this
[__] so just stay curious okay so um
how much flame are you gonna have this
episode I don't know I have so much for
them all the time I don't know what's
wrong with me
okay
how okay take me into what is it like
when you're showering with all the
volleyball players
[Laughter]
what was it like well we wouldn't shower
together we would definitely change
together oh yeah yeah let's slow it down
though yeah do you guys take off the
tops first the bottoms and so like
there's a bunch of girls oh yeah yeah
yeah and like so we come straight after
we finished all of our classes for the
day yeah yeah so we have like our big
bulky backpacks on I don't like bulky
backpacks and then we kind of like
already sweated a bit because it's kind
of stinky we're a little bit musty maybe
yeah because we've been like walking to
school and like from class to class all
day oh so you've been under the sun the
whole time probably yeah most likely and
then we live in like
LA and there's like a lot of smog like
all that Smog and that smoke and that
dust is all up in our hair you guys want
to go home and take a shower first
before practice why would we do that
so I can get turned on
well no unfortunately we didn't do that
so yeah we would go into the locker room
you really want me to explain this to
you yeah
yeah okay tell me this tell me uh first
of all what's it like
um how did you get into volleyball
so this is a fun story so
um going back to Junior High well
anything Junior High and earlier my
parents were highly involved in like my
schoolwork my grades homework I was like
always like a student yeah right now cut
to or fast forward to high school where
I have a little bit more freedom I'm
older hormones I'm an adolescent I think
I'm an adult I Rebel more I [__] have
mood swings so I'm like yeah Freedom
kind of but yeah Freedom I'm like I like
my body's changing I like what do you
mean like your parents give you like I
don't feel like a kid like I I'm not a
kid anymore right because you're in high
school so that's like the beginning of
adulthood yeah and your parents just
didn't give a [__] about you in high
school now I don't
maybe it's my little sister now like
they were more focused on her because
they are six years apart yeah so I don't
know where this shift happened where
they were just like more hands off with
me maybe they just got older and they
were just like [__] it just tired I'm
[__] over these [__] kids I'm
number three you know yeah yeah
so the high school rolls around and my
grades start dipping because I'm just
having fun I'm like ditching I like get
introduced to weed so having the
checkups actually helped you yeah like
having my parents involved at least with
school work and stuff definitely helped
and I think also my mom was
um super involved in my school stuff
because she was part of the same school
district
so she knew a lot of the teachers
especially in elementary schools because
I went to the same Elementary School she
worked at
um Junior High and she still knew a few
teachers and stuff so she could still
check check up on me
High School yeah I don't know what
really happened there but yeah I just
started having more fun and and because
I was on so many restrictions at home
and in my life
that like I couldn't really leave my
house once I was home that's it you know
that was my parents Sheltering me from
you know the environment that our house
was in because it was like the hood and
there's cholos and drugs and just all
the [__] riffraff of just Hood
Behavior yeah so I could never leave the
perimeter of my home so once I went to a
high school it was a high school outside
of you know the district I was supposed
to go to it was in a different city it
was in a a middle a middle class
um or upper upper middle class area so
it was just different crowd different
everything it's not like those Disney
Princess movies are made what do you
mean you know when it's like the
princess that grew up in the palace and
then goes out and explores the real
world with Jasmine yeah except it's the
reverse it's the the well not princess
but like the cholita
it was never a cholita I grew up in the
hood you know barely had a single I
didn't grow up in the hood though like
my house was there but I didn't grow up
there yeah but like you I'm just
gunshots you know there's things you
can't for sure yeah yeah yeah and and
there's a smell of like [__] and piss so
you kind of so you grew up there yeah
and then you're able to like exit the
lands and then explore oh yeah this is
what real life feels like yeah all the
boys look different all the girls look
different like I was like it was just it
was Freedom that was my freedom Devil
Wears Prada like Princess Diaries
Aladdin like all of them are the chick
princess movie when they when in act two
they go into the new world so tell me
did you say Devil Wears Prada she wasn't
even a princess dude she was like an
intern
how [__] dense are you pretty dense
pretty dense we've been together for 15
years it takes a dance person to be with
you she's not from New York
she's in New York she went to well she's
not from the big city working for a huge
magazine in act two her world gets
flipped upside down she works for
someone that's extremely crazy very
demanded she's never felt that before to
the point where she's like I don't even
know if I want to be with my man anymore
it's it's the format please Jesus
[__] Christ well I mean just use the
correct references and then I'll follow
along but
um so what do you think hero's journey
is literally all heroes
no no they don't start off that way but
they do have that element of the no but
they're not literally it's not Superman
and limited to Marvel a hero's journey
is just a hero's just like this this is
I'm gonna call it the princess Journey
it's the template are you calling me a
princess Jesus [__] Christ did you
just say I'm a princess I regret this
topic
um so yeah I'm in high school Freedom
right so me going to school was actually
the way I viewed it back then was this
is me going to hang out like I don't
care that I'm like supposed to do
homework I don't care that I'm supposed
to listen to the teacher I don't even
care that I'm supposed to go to class
I'm just trying to hang out yeah so that
was my hangout because you get to be
outside of the yes yes not even the hood
but just outside of my house okay yeah I
didn't even realize I was in the hood
um so yeah because of that I just
started having a lot more fun my grades
started dipping I was way more into like
smoking weed and not going to class like
um you're on campus but you're just
skipping class yeah I mean I would leave
not as crazy as you can leave campus
right you never like just hop yeah yeah
for sure we did oh you have the fence
yeah we were that era right before they
sealed everything off like uh seniors
could still drive off where would you
guys go to friend's house like I had a
friend that like lived close by like oh
so you walk to people's houses walked or
drive like or like someone had a car
yeah
um that was rare because my mom like
literally knew everyone in that town
because of how many years she worked
there that I'm like uh she could spot me
and I was always so scared like I wasn't
as always as you a bunch of businesses
around the city that [__] ratch you
out
um everyone knew my mom so I was always
very cautious and I would try to stay
within like the like where the houses
were I was so [__] scared so go to
Cerritos like Cerritos Town Center is
right across from Mrs high school and I
don't know what it is but [__]
like they'll know so I looked if we hop
the fence and we go watch movies they'll
be like aren't you supposed to be in
class like the people that are working
there they'll just straight up tell you
that well yeah because it's obvious you
look like a baby yeah but I'm like take
my money you [__]
well they're looking out for you
you think they were being haters well
when I'm 15 I don't think like that when
I'm 15 I'm like man mind your own
goddamn Biz before I [__] you up with my
[__] 100 pound arms
you were really scrawny
um so yeah everything was suffering like
I was just headed down the wrong path
like
um
yeah like I was just I was just a
delinquent I wasn't doing crime or
anything like that but it was it was
rough like I just was like I didn't give
a [__] about anything else so you smoke
weed at the homie's house yeah just hang
out even at on campus like I just didn't
care yeah so then my sophomore year so
uh that year my freshman year I was
failing a few classes I can't even
remember what it was like I think my
average GPA or like my GPA was like
maybe one point something it's probably
English or reading or spelling related
you're such a [__] hater dude
spell no
you know I suck
um so then yeah that was that was that
year and my parents didn't even ask for
my report card which I was always so
surprised but like I would go get the
meal on purpose so I can like get the
report card first and I'm like oh [__]
but they never care to ask I had to even
take summer school and they never really
cared why I wanted to go to summer
school so bad they didn't realize that
like it's because I had to make up these
classes so uh sophomore year rolls
around it's like mid maybe I'm like in
the second semester
of um of my sophomore year and then I
get introduced to this new group of
chicks
um how'd you get introduced to them
maybe maybe class maybe I had a class
with them I can't remember at this point
but um
so they were it was like my girlfriend
group that I still talked to tillisay
and then it was like this new group
um and this was these were more of like
the athlete chicks
um and maybe your first impressions of
them
they were cool like they were just they
were cool did you ever at your school
did you have like this like Athlete on a
pedestal or job for sure oh yeah yeah
yeah for sure when you first were in
their presence where you like that's
pretty cool he's I'm hanging out with
some athletes not really you know I was
like I was more of like the the like
rocker like
um anti-establishment like that type of
crowd like they probably think athletes
are losers
uh we didn't think they were losers but
we just didn't put them on a pedestal
because we're like why we're all the
same people like how are you better than
us
oh because a lot of the Rockers that I
had met yeah they um kind of looked at
athletes like they're lower than like
they almost all have like this like are
you trying like that like are you
actually trying and committing yourself
to something uh well our group my group
of girlfriends we weren't like that it
was like come one come all like it was
just we were just chill as [__] so you
weren't real like anti-establishment no
no not like that I guess but like we
weren't like haters like that we just
kind of stuck to our own crew but then
if people wanted to come in and out of
it like we were the the core four if you
will and then we had a bunch of people
that would like hang out with us and
people would come in here and like go to
another group and kind of people would
bounce around but it was always us for
um and then yeah like we just we didn't
care about other people like we weren't
like oh this person's of this or like we
wouldn't talk [__] like that maybe it's
a guy thing then maybe it's a person
thing I don't know uh that we were all
pretty chill like we got along with a
lot of people
um but yeah when I got introduced to
these this new group of chicks there was
one in particular her name's Roxanne and
she was just like hey you're freaking
tall like um you should play volleyball
and at that point someone else had like
um was she a volleyball player she was
okay she was a volleyball player she was
like a track star she was she played
softball like she's just an all-around
like heavy hitter athlete three times a
day then probably she was she was she
was really musty
um but like prior to her asking me and
this is probably I was more inclined to
do volleyball than anything else so
prior to her asking me maybe within the
same month or like that same period
they had asked me to I forgot who maybe
a coach or a teacher or something was
like hey you should try out for the
basketball team because I'm tall so I'm
like all right [__] it like I I feel
like I need to change in my life like I
just felt like a loser I think so asking
you yeah I think so so before her asking
me that I tried out for the basketball
team oh you actually tried out I did oh
[__] I did because at that point I was
like dude what am I doing with my life
I'm like I don't feel good about myself
I feel productive yeah I just
um I just felt like I was not headed in
the direction I wanted to because one of
those where it's like um in the moment
you're smoking weed skipping classes
super fun and then afterwards you're
like [__] what did I just spend that
whole day on well not really because my
sister was like the pillar of what doing
the right thing
um making my parents proud following the
right like that's the good kid she's the
good kid and I wanted to follow in her
footsteps which were the traditional
footsteps right where it's like you go
to school get good grades you graduate
you go straight to college like you know
that that path like college then you
finish college you get your career then
you find or you get married and then you
buy the house like she did literally the
perfect steps yeah so I knew that's what
I needed to do so when my life was not
going in that right direction because
I'm like if I'm getting a 1.25
um I might not graduate high school
right so like day one you're already
like I already knew what it was yeah I
already knew what it was
um so I let myself get a little lost
that first year and I I just kind of let
loose as much as I allowed myself to
so when sophomore year rolled around I
was like oh man this is horrible like I
only have two more years left and
everyone knows about senioritis and
that's when you're supposed to slack off
and I'm like [__] I'm doing it all wrong
so when I got approached to try out for
the basketball team I was like all right
let's eat it's not gonna hurt
um prior to that I was never into sports
I've never done any sports I was always
like the art kid so I always like danced
a lot and I just I I played like
instruments a lot like I was in band
like I I played a ton of instruments I
took a ton of the art classes and this
is like after school like it's not part
of school yeah I just these were my
extracurricular activities so yeah the
softest hands in the business I did I
still do and then so they threw you a
basketball you're like oh no because my
my brother and my sister were both
athletes so I grew up with my sister who
played basketball yeah but you can't
watch sports no I mean I would play with
her like I was still like I I wasn't
like touching a basketball for the first
time not understanding what was going on
oh you'd play like at the house you know
like just via osmosis right like just
like like you're around it so you're
like you get thrown the ball or like hey
shoot it like you understand like the
basics of things so you knew how to
dribble and stuff yeah enough not like
to [__] do Crossovers and like
putting between my legs and like you
know not nothing fancy yeah
um so yeah I tried out and they were
like smothering the [__] out of me right
and and I'm like I'm like dude get away
I hated it form on the hip I hated it
and I'm like okay bat [__] basketball
this is not for me I hate it I just felt
smothered and I could feel people sweat
and they're just [__] in your
personal bubble and I'm like yo this is
disgusting get away from here take the
ball I don't want it basketball's not
even that much contact compared to like
wrestling for sure I didn't know
remember I didn't play sports so
um yeah after I tried all I'm like yeah
this is [__] for me so when Roxanne
asked me
um if I want to do volleyball I was like
oh that sounds kind of cool I didn't
really know volleyball I never played
volleyball I didn't know [__] about it
and I was like well she's cool and her
Cruise crew cool so it wouldn't hurt to
try you wanna like how close are you
guys
uh no no no because I I mean I knew
enough that I've seen that I'm like okay
everyone stays in their [__] space
and it's divided the Court's divided so
it's like tennis always on that side
yeah it was beautiful so then when I
tried out I was like whoa this is a lot
of fun and I was immediately hooked oh
cool yeah immediately hooked and
um what was tryouts for basketball like
do you remember like the whole day of
sequence of events damn like vaguely you
run suicides you like [__] yeah for sure
yeah because you want to get warmed up
you don't want to get injured before
anything so we did that
um and then they would put us into
different groups because there were so
many people or so many girls uh trying
out that they would go okay you you and
you they switch you in a group you you'd
switch in a group and then they would
watch us play okay you you leave you you
get on and they would just kind of do
you know if you made it I did oh you
actually made it yeah that's why I'm
like oh do you guys yeah because it I
think it's because I was tall I don't
think it's because I was good they were
probably like okay I guess we can use
someone because she can touch the room
without jumping we need it yeah my
school at the time was like highly
highly dense with Japanese Americans and
then
um like our basketball team was actually
really good and we know the height of
them
what does that mean you tell me I don't
know I really don't know what you're
talking about you literally just said
our school was full of Japanese
Americans yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I would just I'm just letting you know
what the population's like yeah so and
then so you're like so I was just that
so and then you went like this no no I
said I probably made it only because I'm
tall because I have no skills and I was
gonna say that
um Japanese Americans at that time were
heavy into leagues yeah so when they
weren't playing like they were already
playing for maybe like five ten years at
that point yeah yeah so they were really
good that's what I meant right so the I
think the only Advantage I probably had
was height yeah
so yeah I made it and I was like now
that that's not for me that's cool I
don't even know what I'm doing that's
cool I made it though is it cool yeah
why because I think it just shows that
like
um some people just naturally got
something yeah I just had height that
was it you naturally got something you
know and I probably had the Latina fire
and that was probably it and I was like
get off me because I'm in fifth grade
I've been playing basketball like
Streetball since I was a kid you know
maybe starting at six or seven and
played all the way until I was 10 and we
would play that like almost every day go
to each other's houses and meet the
three people that lived on my street
that we played all of us had a
basketball court in our front yard so it
was like we would play at our own house
at other people's houses all the time
and when I tried out in fifth grade
um There's A and B Teams they put me on
the B team and I was like
it's [__] up dude I'm like dude you
see how is it like varsity and Junior I
think so I think that that's what
they're trying to do is oh and then so I
played a couple games on the B team but
even then it just felt like I felt so
second in place I'm like what's the
point of even trying yeah and then uh so
I ended up I don't know if I finished or
whatever and then sixth grade came
around and I don't even think I tried
out because I was just like oh you're so
down on yourself yeah so down from even
in fifth grade damn that sucks yeah
yeah so um I ended up trying out and
then I made the team so Roxanne who's
like [__] All-Star MVP player she was
obviously on varsity and I got on JV and
I was like oh oh you guys are the same
year actually no actually so I made the
team and I couldn't play really yeah
um actually I think it was my junior
Year my junior year I couldn't play so I
think sophomore still probably [__]
around sorry it's been a minute
um but my junior year was when I was
like I can't uh I made the team and I
couldn't play because my grades were so
[__] oh no yeah my grades were so
[__] and I was so in love with the
sport and I was like oh so then I tried
out again that's what happened It's All
Coming Back to Me I tried it again my
sophomore year and then I made it
because I was like wait I wasn't a JV
player
um but I was on varsity because I had to
be because I was a [__] senior wait
so you tried out on your freshman year
and then he came back somewhere or you
tried out sophomore junior junior I
tried Junior I made it couldn't play my
grades are [__] so then I tried again
for sophomore and then that's I mean I'm
a senior and then that's when I was able
to play so we only played volleyball for
one year
oh damn yeah I only played it for one
year but I was so in love with the sport
that like I practiced every chance I
could oh wow like I was always playing
all the time yeah did were you sorry
when did the phlegm problem I don't know
maybe after I stopped smoking weed maybe
did you ever go [__] I wish I would have
100 played volleyball for all four years
100 really yeah I loved it so much I
didn't know and like I didn't know who
the [__] plays volleyball in the hood
that's true you know what I mean like
all the [__] Hood Parks I went to
there's no [__] volleyball nets yeah
like there's no volleyball nets in
[__] East L.A that's gonna get stolen
yeah we don't have that [__] yeah
um and then uh I I didn't even realize
that my neighbor was actually a
volleyball player but he's my brother's
age so I didn't know and it and it
wasn't until he saw me like trying to
set yeah like just practicing my sets
and he was like wait what the hell like
you're playing volleyball and I'm like
yeah I tried out and then he was like I
play volleyball and then he became my
pepper my pepper friend well it's
probably because you try to keep it a
secret
I mean I
don't know too many volleyball players
are proud of what they do
you're [__] hate
and hate the Olympic volleyball players
are [__] so happy you don't have a
[__] metal those guys are you don't
have a metal you hater I follow a couple
of uh Olympic medalists no no just
volleyball players at the super high
level yeah because they get up I'm
talking about waste over the net like
who the [__] doesn't follow not that
level of athlete though like you don't
make any [__] sense I don't know I
just follow random Joe's that just
[__] do random things at a random
level anyone that interests me I follow
them yeah so so of course I mean that's
majority of the people dude and majority
of the people are going to follow
athletes that are doing [__]
extraordinary things hezboola I follow
and this MMA skills suck but you don't
follow him for his MMA skills I do
follow him precisely for his MMA skills
no you don't I do
what do you think about his skills
they're very interesting to watch
I've like rarely see him do [__] MMA
stuff yeah he tried to stalk Mike Tyson
yeah that's not MMA he tried and then
Mike Tyson picked him up and hugged them
and kissed him in the ear like he's a
baby yeah don't [__] disrespect
Hezbollah like that okay he's not a baby
no he's like 19 now no he's old as [__]
he's older he's probably older than us
what how old is he he's like 19. is he
really when he came on to scene he was
18. he might really he might be 20 now
now I gotta like this [__] I thought he
was older than us
no no he's he's
young okay well what else do you want to
know I'm looking this up I'm listening
to your story
I don't know where I left off yeah
oh yeah he's only 20 years old he only
played for one year I [__] up yeah in
high school did that ever uh take you
into a spot like did that ever transcend
into
any type of parenting precautions
what do you mean like you know for me oh
[__] you know like for me um
remember I've told you many times like
one of the things that I thank my mom
the most is pushing me to get my black
belt on Kung Fu because uh when I was
like brown belt I went to Taiwan for a
whole month and at that time you forget
things real quick so when I came back I
was so like so embarrassed and shamed
that I forgot everything I was just
gonna quit but my mom pushed me and she
was like it doesn't matter
um we're gonna go to the park on the
weekends we'll work on the forums
together and then you start class back
as a white belt just wear a white belt
and then we'll slowly bring you back to
where you're supposed to be and because
of that that kind of like precaution
made it into my parental mind so in my
mind I'm like okay cool if I ever see
taika hit that big roadblock I'm gonna
stick it through with them no matter
what because that was so helpful for my
mom that I was able to achieve something
and then that helped me achieve other
things in the future so I want to make
sure that I'm there for Tycho when he
has that moment too did that ever like
go into your parental brain or like
um
because you know you regret not playing
four years so like do you ever go okay I
don't regret it because I I can't blame
myself like regret is such a heavy maybe
you don't mean regret but I don't have
any heaviness for it because I'm like I
didn't know or you wished oh okay okay
yeah you know like you wished you could
have played four years does that ever go
like I want to make sure that uh taika
tries to experience as little of the
wishfulness as possible
um I don't think so because I don't know
if that's something that we can really
control right like we can only expose
him to a lot uh let me rephrase that we
can only expose him
um as much as with the stuff that we
know right but
I guess in retrospect I would say if if
anything if any if that taught me
anything for the parental brain as you
call it it'd be more like um just being
more curious about things but then I
don't know because like how do you know
you're missing out on something that
you don't even know exists well that's
what happened to me
I didn't actually quit and then regret
it you know what I mean I went through
with it but after going through with it
I was like oh [__] I see the importance
of having your parents help push you
through things yeah because you're not
able to push through it yourself yeah I
mean I didn't have that my mom was the
opposite or my parents that's my
situation yeah for your situation you
don't go like oh [__] okay
um it's really important to take
advantage of things at a younger age
because time will only go by like you'd
oh you could only play high school
sports once yeah so make sure that you
maximize High School sports like in your
parental brain yeah I don't know if I
learned it at that time time like at
that time I'm saying now now that you're
a parent did any of that make it into
your parents 100 like a lot of stuff
that I went through all went straight
into the parental brain like uh that
experience alone I can draw like and be
like yeah if there's something that
really clicks for you like that was the
first time I felt passion that I could
remember at least
um well no that's not the first time
that's the second time and I think
because I felt it the second time I was
like oh [__] I need to like really write
this the first time was when I was
dancing ballet like I fell in love with
that
like instantly like I wasn't even I was
never interested in ballet the only
reason why I got into it was because my
little sister got into it and my mom was
like okay well your little sister wants
to do it and I'm like I don't want to do
that thing that thing's whack
um and then she goes just try it you'll
like it you never know and I'm like nuts
whack my sister went to a few classes
and then finally I was like all right
well I don't want to just be home and
then when I actually did it that day I'm
like holy [__] I'm [__] hooked and I
hadn't experienced that so when
volleyball volleyball rolled around and
I got into it I'm like holy [__] this is
badass like it replaced that passion
that I was missing from ballet and I'm
like oh my God if I feel this like I'm
gonna stick through to it so that
definitely taught me like when you feel
that like you're you're just so anxious
to like try it again and you just can't
stop like I couldn't stop thinking about
it I was just obsessed
um that anytime I do see that in taika
I'm like really gonna help him like
stick with it do you see that in Taco at
all now basketball he loves basketball
yeah yeah that's why I would make the
joke when he um would get into stuff
like let's say he was showing a lot of
love for I don't know drawing and you're
like guess what babe I just signed him
up for BJJ and I'm like perfect yeah
because that's exactly what he wants you
can't remember that joke or like he'd be
showing more interesting cooking you're
like guess what babe I just [__]
signed him up for drum lessons and I'm
like okay awesome
so yeah that's for sure taught me that
it also taught me that like
um
there's no real mistake you can't really
change
you know like at that time because I I
was flunking so hard and my life was so
it felt so [__] to me and it felt like
I was just so derailed from the person I
once was which was that a student like
that obedient kid
um and I felt like I really lost myself
for those first couple of years in high
school
that like I just felt like I legit felt
like a loser in America
yeah what do you mean only in America
can you disappear for 30 days or 90 days
to be realistic and then come back like
unrecognizable
explain like in Asia
you [__] up one semester you're going to
be a janitor the rest of your life oh
because it's so competitive yeah like if
you don't do good in junior high you
don't do good in high school if you
don't do good in high school you don't
do good in college yeah and then that's
why like during finals week they seal
all the top floors of the schools
because kids literally jump off the
building and commit suicide like they
get one life is [__] yeah they get one
beat and they go well they think that's
it I
like you need to have like perfect
scores to even have a chance in choosing
what you want to be because it's so
[__] competitive oh wow you know but
only in America where you can give
someone 90 days and they can depend on
how well they can cram information or
bump up their Fitness like someone could
be unrecognizable in 90 days if they
really put their mind to it you know
yeah oh that's awesome yeah I mean it
taught me that for sure that like
um
yeah I can I can come back from it
because I really felt like I hit such a
rock bottom like that was when I was the
first time I was ever really and
obviously it's the age too because
there's just so many changes happening
but that was the first time I like
really considered suicide like
um I felt so down on myself I was like
shoplifting I mean I didn't do I think I
only shoplifted like once that's
probably just for fun too for sure but
it was still not who I wanted to be and
you know I was fortunate enough that I
caught it within myself early enough
where I'm like ooh I don't like this
person like I just knew I needed such a
drastic change so when volleyball
presented itself I'm like this is this
is it this is my sign to change it
um and and not to blame my my friend
group because they really didn't do
anything wrong like they were great
group of girls but I just felt like I
needed to change everything so like I
even left my girl group and I just like
completely just started like a whole
fresh start with like your friends from
volleyball yeah how is that Dynamic was
it like did they it's cool they but were
did your old friends like kind of feel
like you left them or was there any bad
feelings maybe yeah maybe they did feel
that way but I think at that point you
know people started getting boyfriends
and like uh one girl started working
another one had like a boyfriend she was
obsessed with another one was more into
partying so we kind of all just like had
our like secondary groups that we would
jump around in and we would come back on
occasion
um but eventually I got so laser focused
on what my goals were and like I already
knew my path that like eventually we
lost contact especially after we
graduated high school because I'm like
oh I need to start achieving my [__] and
then did you think Sports helped you
bring absolutely yeah absolutely because
like I needed a minimum right and then
um
um like their influence was way more
positive too because like they all
wanted to get into better schools and
bigger schools and play here and get a
scholarship there and
um yeah they just were from what I can
see they just seemed like they were in
better places
wouldn't volleyball do you apply in your
day-to-day life now
uh the first one is just being a team
player like one is we all have our
positions right we all have our
strengths but we also all have our
weaknesses
um constant communication so like
just saying what it is that you're doing
and letting the rest of your team know
what's up right so like something as
small as like
um when some someone sends me a message
just letting them know hey received or
hey I got it I'll reply whenever just
that constant communication because then
you know during a game like you have to
let people know because everyone's
running for the same ball unless you go
hey hey if it's like right between you
and I I got it I got this one right uh
the other one is just learning your
position and playing your position to
the fullest uh and letting others I was
a middle blocker
so you just is it like three in the
front and in the middle yeah
and you just jump up and you block yeah
I mean I also was a hitter
um was it hit or mean like Assassin
like you know when they spike the ball
yeah like you hit it yeah but my
position was always in the middle so you
would like smack it down on him yes are
you pretty good at spiking I was all
right well why do you say you're all
right I don't know I guess if we would
that's that's the only thing that I'm
like damn it I wish I wish I grew up in
an era where like video phones were in
yeah like I have no footage of me
playing I know like I have no video
nothing like I have nothing I have zero
footage of my wrestling and I'm kind of
happy that it's like that yeah no I
would have loved to have seen it you
know what I mean like I didn't have
parents that were there with [__]
camcorders and [__] like I have nothing
the one that I'm the most not sad but
like that feeling about is actually
military
oh what part I thought you're not even
supposed to film well no no once you
make it to your unit
uh you know things got more and more
lacks yeah you know before it was like
like let's say you go to uh um some
outdoor Galleria right you bring out a
camera hey private property no filming
yeah and then now I think people just
know and you bring out the phone hey
don't film me but now everyone's like
there's no way of stopping this so
literally filming is allowed everywhere
now yeah right unless someone goes I
don't want to be on camera but you need
it needs person to person but there's no
like facility rule yeah so now I see all
kinds of crazy military footage come out
because it's just on their phone or
they're recording for themselves or
whatever right but I've got to see a lot
of really cool [__]
that I wish I had footage for yes
because I share it yeah because like
because you know tiger always talks
about my fungus feet and I just want to
join the military because I got fungus
feet from it and I'm like but you
actually see really cool stuff and he
was like what and he's into Jets I was
like Papa once saw uh a jet come and
drop a bunch of missiles
like that because of a specific like
coordinates that someone called in and
we were staying out there for like four
days and he goes wow
but I don't have yeah isn't that a
bummer any footage of that you know yeah
so yeah I wish I would have I wish I
would have seen some some of my plays
but yeah I was a middle blocker
um
yeah so I didn't play back row because
like at that point well this this is not
high school high school doesn't I mean
the one I went to at least my time
didn't have liberals and they were like
what's a libero um so they're the ones
that like you know when the when the
other team like they send it yeah they
send it over yeah not even necessarily a
serve but like let's say they spike it
yeah usually you tend to spike it in the
middle to the back row like anyone that
tends to hit it excuse me within the
10-foot line which is like the line God
damn it where the front row would be
it's really hard to do that that means
you have to have [__] mad hops for it
to go straight down yeah right because
there's a net goes straight down so
that's like the 10 foot line like the
people so that's rare guys can do it
right because they have mad hops guy
that is also higher but um yeah it is
rare so because they tend to go more in
the middle to back row you have someone
that's a passing specialist because
um it all starts with the pass if you
have a shitty past and you're probably
gonna have a shitty set
like a set and then if you have a shitty
set then you're probably going to have a
shitty [__] Spike so is the the pasta
or the libero person is almost in charge
of like kind of neutralizing that attack
of course like a very nice ball in the
air everyone has time to gather
literally they're bearings yeah that's
the whole responsibility yeah literally
so they're the ones working like in the
middle so like the way you tend to move
on the court is kind of like there's
always different formations but the most
common one is kind of like a teardrop so
the teardrop the T the Tipping the tip
of the teardrop is what your Setter is
right so we always kind of follow the
setter wherever they go so then the
outside hitters will go on the side of
the setter because that's usually where
they're going to set the ball right and
then the middle blocker my position
would go kind of a little bit back so
that the setter can run funny
front and back so I can get the ball too
so then she has so we have full defense
around the center so anywhere she goes
we're like this and then you have the
back to the back hitters then you have
your little Barrel in the kind of like
moving around in the middle and then so
she's she's always like she passes in
the touches yeah so let's say she she
passes it and it's too close to the net
to where the other team can like spike
it on us because it's just right at the
net then we have these other other two
defensive players like ready to receive
it to pass it to the setter so then the
setter can like set the ball really
nicely how often because I know it's
usually like three hits here and then
three hits here right yeah how often do
you think that's the max do you guys
break the Rhythm like does it ever just
go like I see their position also
absolutely liberal straight through the
header right to the center yeah
sometimes the center will go up for a
set and she sees that there's like the
middle is open or this area like right
behind her is open she puts her hands up
to set it and then she'll just tip it
over and then like there's no one there
in that position like all the time you
can break the rules all the time who's
usually the hottest
um the middle blockers really no the
whole team is high what are you talking
about there's not the hottest one
like like the the star or what do you
mean usually the outside hitters are the
badasses because they get the sexiest
ones they're all sexy dude because I've
seen someone that look like they outgrew
their their body
what does that mean like they look like
they they like
they've been in Arizona Sun
Arizona's sun and outgrew their body
what are you talking about you put like
a cassette tape outside in the Arizona
Sun and then when you come visit it four
hours later it looks different what the
[__] is a cassette tape dude a [__]
cassette tape I don't even know what
happens when you put it in the sun it
kind of like droops down and outgrows
itself
I don't know what you're saying are you
calling them old looking no some of them
just don't look that hot because they
look outgrowing I mean that's just a lot
of people that's true like if everyone
looked hot as [__] we would all be in
[__] Vogue models right but if I'm
trying to get horny which one should I
get horny to the one that's your [__]
wife you [__] trash bucket
so the one that got a 1.5 GPA yeah
one seven before you did 0.17 yeah
that's still pretty good you know what's
[__] crazy so I had really shitty
grades right really shitty yeah but I'm
also really smart
right so
like I was so uh like stupid smart
that I can look at all my grades and I
can calculate the GPA like that
like three A's Three B's what is that I
don't know 3.5 nice because all of them
are scored fours and threes right so
that's how good I was like I can look at
them oh that's 2.83 or that's 0.17
because I can do the average immediately
the thing is I couldn't apply that to
class yeah so 0.17 means you have like
all F's One D so that one D divided by 6
is 0.17 yeah I'm lost too many numbers
dude you don't know how to take an
average or something
um I do but I just don't want to hear it
[Laughter]
do you
do right now it's like is obsessed with
with McMahon and aren't you proud no I
love it I absolutely love it but all I
hear is Mama what's 1 million plus one
thousand minus one plus two and I'm like
it's one million whatever whatever
whatever right but like you keep doing
it you're doing shut up you're doing all
the math right now I'm like oh God here
we go with tiger again that's because so
like that's the ironic thing where I did
so poorly in school but me being able to
calculate grades and take averages ABCs
and like that like yeah it shows how
good I actually am and how much
information was retained it just wasn't
reflected in my homework or the tests
yeah well I mean now it's dope that like
we have so much more
um education as like
education providers and teachers and
counselors and stuff that we understand
that now when a kid not we like I'm part
of the thing but like as a society that
we understand when a kid's doing bad in
school it's not necessarily because
they're academically behind or slow I
mean that can be the case but now we
know to look into like the family
structure or the environment that
they're growing up in and going oh wait
there might be other things at play here
and it's sad that like they didn't have
that for you at that time
but here we are together [__] 15
years together
um I don't know I feel like you knew
this stuff about me no well I'm trying
to dig a little bit deeper so oh did you
get anything new
um a little bit I didn't realize that
you tried out and then didn't make it
because uh no I made it I just I
couldn't play exactly you couldn't make
it academically yeah I was so [__]
sad for some reason my brain I thought
you played all four years no I only
played one year because I think every
time I talk to someone that likes
volleyball oh yeah my wife played four
years High School no one year I've been
lying the whole time and then it was
cool that I even got to play in college
that part is cool that's [__] red did
you only play one year in high school or
college uh I played uh
I played
two two years and I redshirted one year
what's the biggest difference between
um everything the college and high
school everything yeah college is like
it's like talking about like uh Junior
High basketball right like it's very
basic yeah yeah you still have like this
is the point guard this is the [__]
whatever right like everyone has their
positions but it's not that organized
you don't have strategy
um your skills aren't refined enough to
where you can like specifically shoot
from certain spots the spots aren't
numbered for you like when it came to
college I knew so many different hits so
many different positions so now your
accuracy it's like you could spike it
100 but like wherever you are they would
tell me like the coach would be like hey
so like the core our court side could be
divided into six it's uh divided into
six sections right yeah well actually
seven because you have the the setter
and then within each section you divide
that again another six times so he would
tell you hey I want you to serve it into
this corner but within this corner put
it on that corner you know and like we
just had like we had like number like
like if we wanted a specific set it was
a specific number so like now we're
communicating with the setter with our
numbers behind our back and like there's
just so much strategy like it's two
different worlds you have laser
Precision like that not anymore I
haven't touched the volleyball in
[__] decades like you did before I
mean yeah that was pretty good you think
before it could you could have gone into
a classroom and like let's say you just
randomly want to smack someone on the
head for sure oh for sure I'm sure
you're gonna hit them for sure oh [__]
yeah for sure I mean you spent so much
time [__] uh hitting balls that's
badass yeah for sure
that's pretty cool what about um and
then like there's a spinning on the ball
like you can have the ball go straight
but then it goes off to the side you can
have the ball go like it goes fast no I
mean I would have I'm so [__] you can
have the ball start really fast and then
slow down at the end like it's just it's
like a like a pit you know how a pitcher
can like has so many different pictures
same thing with a hit wow same thing
that's pretty cool it's super cool
there's so much going on you ever want
to get back into it every [__] time
yeah I love it I love it so much have
you Googled Las Vegas no not yet I don't
know if I'm making a spot where I want
to like if I want to get into it like I
want to make sure all my bases are
covered first before I can play and I
don't feel like I have any basis covered
before I could play you want to play
volleyball you set up a volleyball net
in her backyard that's cute we have that
little grass yeah who am I gonna play
with you me I'm just kidding we would
play in the house remember yeah I get
good at anything fast yeah you do you're
actually pretty good so did you get what
you wanted yeah I guess I got a little
glimpse into
what a mess I used to be well mainly I
just wanted to get some more shower
scenes in my head I'm glad I gave you
all the musty ones yeah all right well
anything else you want to ask before we
go no more questions your honor all
right cool anything else you want to add
yeah make sure to go check out Barbara
Brigade we always got dope stuff thank
you for listening to this podcast
Barbara Gates sponsor this podcast what
makes all this possible go to
barbourgate.com we got supplements
apparel like what I'm wearing uh digital
training and we always have funny videos
uh training and mainly we just get my
ass piece to go check that out oh that's
the best all right guys thank you so
much for listening we'll talk next week
week bye